so he's he asks um do you have any
advice on how to go from a one-liner
chameleon
to longer form bits while still keeping
the quick hard punches
yeah right great question so one you
know
if you take a look at brian kiley brian
kylie is
conan o'brien's head monologue writer he
he is
a he is a mechanical just like comedic
mechanics
you know down to the t right he
has found a way to sort of make the make
the flow
of the material sound like it's almost a
complete story so it rolls very nicely
even though they're individual jokes now
the key is i think you can take a story
or concept so i'll start like one and
two liners
uh sometimes and then it'll evolve into
a story a whole story about
um my relationships my failed
relationships and then
but within the story all of the lines
every sentence gives you an opportunity
for a joke
right so um like when i first do a joke
about
uh meeting my wife for the first time i
do a quick joke about that that could be
done
but then like if i say um my wife
uh it was my wife's birthday the other
day and for her birthday i got her a
gift certificate for his
and her massage and she said jerry
this is a wii gift not a me
gift so i returned it and got her a gift
certificate for dinner for one
and then you know then i can just talk
more about my wife you know my wife
my wife and i we've been married about
15 years and
all of this now this theme is running
along and there could be individual
jokes weaved together with tag stoppers
and act outs
and that's what makes it feel like it's
now a story or a bit
you'll notice that most of the best
comics you know
even sometimes the one and two liners um
they'll get up there and they'll do an
act out and knocked out just shows up as
an organic piece of the joke so we don't
think about it as an act out
and they'll get into an act out you
watch them on a tv set they'll get into
that act out within the first 30 seconds
and that makes the audience feel like
it's a whole story so there once they
see that act out once they imagine
this in the scenario you just set up
with the act out you've got them
compelled they're seeing your sitcom
that you're shooting and showing them
right there in front of their face
by acting it out because they have that
suspension of disbelief sort of like we
have in theater
you know we know the guy's not at a
stream right now but he's splashing his
face with water that's not
not there but we buy it because it's a
it's a play and we suspend our disbelief
same thing happens in stand up when you
do an act out all of a sudden the
audience is seeing the pictures
that you're creating and they're in your
story so it could be
one joke but done with an act out it
just really helps that joke evolve into
a bit
yes yeah and that yeah that's great too
to
people to understand a lot of times
these longer bits were actually
smaller individual bits that evolved
over
time and kind of you found themes to tie
them so they
seem like it's one long story but it was
a bunch of individual jokes
that just kind of organically formed
into one yeah
and it's an application of the structure
right so if you say okay you say the
joke and you go okay well if this is
true what else is true mm-hmm
and then you could tap and so if this
happened what would that look like
there's the act down
right yeah so then you can say um
you know uh what's my what is what are
the you know who what where why when and
how
what's the contrasting perspective what
is that
well some people think this i think this
and now you're evolving it even more
so you're just taking it and using your
your your ideas and your techniques
definitely the maximum of the five w's
is one of your best assets
who what where why when and how who who
what who me
who who else is involved who else would
this impact
you know uh who would hate this who
would really like this
you know who would think this was stupid
you know that girl right there oh that's
stupid you know she's you know this
so then how would you respond if she
insulted you or he insulted you
you know now you have a benign
retaliation possibility so
that who where why went out and how can
really take that story and evolve
if you're serious about becoming a
comedian join our facebook group linked
in the description below to start
getting tips like these
every single day and watch this playlist
of our top writing tips to improve your
writing today